hey guys I'm Ryan Wright tonight I'm
gonna be watching the trailer for a
movie called pan I have not seen the
trailer for this movie yet I have not
seen the trailer for this movie yet I
didn't you know like catch it in the
theaters and all of already seen is so
this is gonna be a very genuine reaction
no no none of it is gonna be fake it's
all gonna be very real very genuine very
sincere it is no [ __ ] reaction you
guys ready for this pan all right I
don't know what it's about is about
frying pan this is about a frying pan uh
Warner Brothers good company good
company Peter oh it's Peter Pan well we
had a mom I don't even know who Joel
Wright is but I'm [ __ ] excited I long
for the day that I can come back for you
and explain everything
yeah yeah he's going to be it's a
[ __ ] nun oh he was a rebel he was a
rebel
it could be Neverland whoa what the what
the [ __ ]
no no no no no horrible horrible things
are happening right now okay
it's Christopher Walken hahaha that's
the first time I'm making that joke I'll
laugh
you know I'm getting lost in the music
the untold story okay cool
what look they were friends before Oh
Rooney Mara I like to think sexual stuff
of her God
Oh God funny [ __ ] it was you Jackman
oh the guy from Sean
Wow good for you leave on Miller yes
shut yeah shut Peter you should
that looks moving it's like I'm moving
IMAX first time I'm discovering that wow
what a trailer that was my first time
watching it yep okay look I know my
hacking skills are [ __ ] the superior
beyond belief but can't lie to you guys
I was faking that the whole time I have
seen this trailer before I'm sorry I
feel like I lied but I'll try to give a
serious trailer review instead I
genuinely do like everything that's
going on in this movie I could be like a
[ __ ] about it and be like oh it's
another origin tale or I can just accept
the fact that that's an origin tale and
that it's a different origin tale about
a different character so that way I
don't you know get like [ __ ] annoyed
over nothing I think it's a cool origin
tale to explore you know I don't
remember if hook in Peter Pan we're
supposed to be friends I don't the fact
that we're seeing them as like little
buddies beforehand or he's a little
buddy and he's an older buddy which is
kind of a creepy relationship because
once clearly an adult thing they don't
want a kid so who knows what's gonna
happen there maybe that's why pan
doesn't like hook so much you know what
I mean maybe he used his hook and that's
a little boy I am joking about I've seen
the neverland world before Peter Pan was
the [ __ ] king of the neverland world
so it's really neat to me to actually
see this before tale I think this could
be cool I think this could be a cool
franchise in a lot of ways because the
Peter Pan story has been redone and
redone and redone but you know it's like
I feel like we can actually get a lot of
new things out of this a lot of fresh
things out of this and if they do make
sequels down the road it'll be [ __ ]
awesome because you can get characters
we haven't even heard of before yet so
that'd be exciting and you know Hugh
Jackman like everyone loves him as
Wolverine but it's always exciting for
me to see him like do another role that
is not Wolverine since he's played
Wolverine I think 47 times
and I love watching Rooney Mara you know
I Garrett Hedlund or whatever the [ __ ]
that guy's a mess he's good-looking I
don't really care to you know watch his
performance that I'm not really
captivated by
work he's done but you know who knows he
might be a cool hook you might hook me
in and rooney mara [ __ ] fantastic at
you keep trying to convince my
girlfriend to watch other Girl with the
Dragon Tattoo no wait not my girlfriend
my boyfriend Gary I'm trying to convince
Jerry to watch The Girl with the Dragon
Tattoo because of how great of an
actress Rooney Mara isn't it and
visually they you know like it does have
like that cool fantasy vibe about it a
lot of movies trying to be all fantasy
but you know it tends to look good but
it doesn't always feel you know magic
and I feel like this movie might be able
to capture that actual magical spirit
and sort of bring that feeling out of us
anyway thanks for telling me that
trailer was out didn't know that wait no
I already reveal that I've seen it
before if you're new to the channel you
can subscribe to the real rejects where
we're so real that today's episode is a
perfect example of how real we can be
we're so not real that we don't even
spell real with an A we were we [ __ ]
clever and I can't believe no one's done
this before we spelled it with an E
it's a play on words like dumb real
Gustavo Alonso for the love of giant
hairy balls
can I get a shout-out also you guys are
awesome keep it up giant hairy balls was
my nickname back in preschool that's
right I develop you big hair way before
hanging my friends did freak me the [ __ ]
out I thought semen was milk it was whoa
Gustavo dude that sounds like a sexy
name Gustavo Alonzo dude he must be one
sexy [ __ ] if you're a sexy
[ __ ] that means you do have
giant hairy balls keep it up don't ever
shave them most girls love the hair
quote me on that Raptor man Sam hey can
I get a shout-out on your next video
you're Mexican I'm Mexican so why not
I'm not Mexican I'm just [ __ ] around
no I have no problems in Mexicans my
girlfriend is actually Mexican
yeah she's a little hot ask me Pina huh
right raptor man Sam you are Mexican
which is cool my girlfriend's Mexican so
maybe you're related I'm assuming all
Mexicans are related in some way they
just have to it's as basic science so ya
raptor man Sam dude you keep up with the
with the feeling of feeling like a
velociraptor because they are [ __ ]
cool ass animals man they learn how to
open doors did you learn how to open
your door shadow the Lord shut up please
well shadow the Lord you sound like
you're a spawn of Satan I grew up with
Catholic beliefs so Satan and I we're
not cool friends I don't think I can
associate with you shadow cuz you bring
out the darkness in people the light
doesn't shine upon us anymore is it the
shadow of the Lord
wow wow I should join an improv group
Thank You shadow the Lord you've
inspired me